how do Sony film simulations work
straight out of camera Sony colors might
come a little bit off and not as
pleasing as we like it to but I have a
little fix for you by applying custom
settings we can shift and remap colors
in different directions correcting Sony
colors and making them look quite
amazing so here's a little secret sauce
lower the temperature by 2,000 Kelvin
and then go into the color filter and
push it to Amper 7 and to crack the
camera tint either go M into one or
green one depending on your camera Color
cast and from here you can use the
picture profile menu to further refine
your color if we check the before and
after we can definitely notice the color
shift happening especially in the
yellows which is very very important for
the skin tones further proving you can
correct son colors straight out of
camera and get amazing jpx without any
color
grading